gel
[Müzik]
buraya davet edildiğim den beri
düşünüyorum Acaba ne anlatmak lazım ki
herhalde davet edildiğimiz için
tecrübelerinizden faydalanmak istemiştir
arkadaşlarımıza düşündüm ben de o
tecrübelerden başlayayım maske konusuna
gelince benim hayatım
hadi bir daha önce de maske takarak
geçti
başkalarının
bana dayattığı ya da sevdiği şeyleri
maskesini takarak büyüdüm ben mesela çok
arabayı Sarardım lisede Eve gidince
dinlerdim Okula gelince Freddie Mercury
seviyorum verdi Çünkü ondan hoşlanıyor
herkes başarılı oluncaya kadar başarı
Gerçekten insan çok karizmatik
gösteriyor başarılı olunca ne olacakları
maskeler takıp kendinizi başka biriymiş
gibi göstermeniz gerekebiliyor
yıllar geçince anladım ki aslında hiçbir
değeri yok şimdi de sosyal medya maske
taktığı sizi
sananlara mesela geçen gün bir arkadaş
geldi senaryosunu getirdi beğenmediğimi
söyledim çok kızdı bana
[Müzik]
çünkü bu her sabah
Bu bir lahmacun resmi koyuyor
Instagram'a 80 90 tane beğeni alıyor Bu
beni almaya alışmış İnsanlar bir gün
karşılarında birisinin Onların yaptığı
şey beğenmediğini söyleyince tepki
veriyor olmaya başladılar
Bu bayramda bir teyzeme gittim
8 takipcisi var sabah şey yazmıştı
bayramda elini öpmeye gittik
ve bütün İslam aleminin bayramını
kutlarım yazmış sadece 8 takipçi var ve
o sırada o sekizin 8'de evde salonunda
bulunuyor Ben de ona dedim ki yani
yazmana gerek yok teyze zaten 8 kişi
takip hepsi buradaydım Şaka yaptım o da
bana kusura bakma biz senin gibi ünlü
değiliz dedi
Küstü bana gerçekten şimdi yaklaşırken
arkadaşlarada şey yaklaşıyor Ne herkes
ünlü olabilir
herkesin like alması ve beğenilmesi
başka bir kafaya soktu insanları Fakat
ben de hayatın boyunca
hep şöyle süre geldi
kendimi beğendirmek için deli gibi
çalışmam lazım
12 yaşından beri çalışıyorum buraya
çıkan başarılı olan herkesin anlattığı
gibi Çünkü başarılı olmak için ne gibi
çalışmamız gerekiyor Çok Çalışkan
olmanız gerekiyor bir arkadaşımla
karşılaştım kendisi diş doktoruna
liseden aramızda en şanslı Sen dinledi
Çünkü ben herkes Sana da bir iş yaptım
şunu gözünde şanslıyım Hayır bu kiliseye
geri dönsek Ben onun yerinde olup Çapa
Tıp kazanmak isterim
ben o sırada kendimi işsiz ve aylık
birisi olarak gördüğüm için Çalışmaktan
başka şansım olmadı düşündüğüm için Ama
hayatta azmederek doğru yerde bulunarak
ve süreklilik benim hayatımı bu noktaya
getiren en önemli şey sürekliliktir
deli gibi çalışıp işi bırakmayıp ve o
şansın bana gelmesini bekledim ben şunu
kesin söyleyebilirim size
şans denen şey Azmi aşık yani siz ne
kadar Azimli olursanız o şans geliyor
size orada bir gün yakalıyor buluyor ve
hayatta başkalarına Keşke kendinizi
farklı göstermeye çalışman bir manası
olmadığını çeşitliliğin ve her şeyi
seviyorum anasına güzel bir şey olduğunu
anladı mesela Çocukluğumda lise
yıllarımı Erkin Koray'ın yanında
çalışıyorum gece işte sabaha kadar
çalışıyoruz sonra sabah okula gidiyorum
öğleden sonra eve geliyorum Sonra da bu
İbrahim Tatlıses'le çalışmaya başladım
ve şöyle bir hayatım olmaya başladı
sabah uyanıyoruz Erkin baba evde
bana nefes almak vermek ritim midir
değil midir onu anlatıyor soreje Total
dinliyoruz öğleden sonra ben işe
gidiyorum boş oldu çalışıyorum ve Kara
Üzüm Habbesi le halay çekiyoruz hep
beraber Ve bu çok
mükemmel bir şey olduğunu bu zaman
geçtikten sonra anladım ve başkasının
maskesinde bürünmek gerekmediğini kendi
doğrularınla isteseydin gerekiyor olmak
gerektiğini düşündüm azim ve orada
bulunmak meselesinde şöyle anlatayım
hayatını nasıl değiştirdiğini
Ben birisi beni kova kovana kadar işleri
hiç ayrılmadım
Komedi Dükkanı yapılıyor Tolga harika
bir projem var diye geldi zaten o sırada
bizim benim çalıştığım şirketin Avrupa
Yakası dizisinde oynuyor hayranım
kendisine getirse tabi başımızın üstüne
diyoruz dedi ki bunu yapmak istiyorum Bu
bir tanıtım gibi birşey Çekerim Ben de
bunu gideyim kanalları satmaya
çalışıyorum tabi dedi Sonra dedim ki ben
yapımcıyı mor oyuncu değilim
tanıtımı çektik çok komik oldu ben Tolga
bağırıyorum Tolga bana cevap veriyor
falan biliyorsunuz işte efsane proje
Sonra dedi ki kim olsun birini bulalım
dedim gerçekten çok yetenekli çok iyi
yazar bir arkadaş işin içine dahil oldu
ilk program ve ilk programı seyirciler
davet edildi Tolga sahneye çıktı o
arkadaşımız mikrofonun başına geçti ve
ben dışarıdayım her şey kendi kendine
ilerlerken biraz da
durumv mi istediği gibi Tolga'nın
olmuyordu Çünkü bizim şeyde yaptığımız
antrenman Daha önce yaptığımız tanıtım
şeklindeki antrenmanda daha iyi
hissediyordu kendisini Ben döndüm Acil
eve gitmem lazım de bir hiç geldi içime
Her şey yolunda gidiyor Benim dönmem
lazım dedim bir taksi çağırdım bu taksi
Geldi durdu
taksi duruncaya rejide ki arkadaşlardan
birisi bana şu bir şey söyledi abi
gidiyor musun dedim şimdi abi gidiyor
musun deyince ben gitmem gerekiyor diye
düşünmeye başladım sonra kendi kendime
dedim ki rencide çalışan birisinin bana
bir yapımcı ağabey gidiyormusun
dediğinde gitmem gerekiyor ve burada
olmam gerekiyor sonra bu sahibi olmak
gerekiyor dedim
Taksiye de kusura bakma kardeşlik
gönderdim Bir dakika sonra Tolga
sahneden çıktı arkaya geldi Sen geç
mikrofonu dedi
Ayıp olmaz mı dedim Olmaz dedi Hemen sen
geç mikrofona dedi ben mikrofona geçtim
2007 yılının Ağustos ayıydı 16 yıl oldu
mm den fazla oyun oynadık birlikte
harika bir iş oldu benim için benim
Kariyerim için hayatımı değiştirdi onun
hayatını değiştirdi bir sürü şey oldu
hayatımızda sonra yani orada o an orada
bulunduğunuzda o şans gelip size diyor
ki sen bu ne oluyorsun sağ bitsin ve
azmediyorsun diyor ve sizi yakalıyor
arkadaşlar Arkasından da hemen şu onu
başlıyor Kaç Para kazanacağız
Tabii ki para kazanılıyor her bizim işte
çok iyi para kazanıyor fakat
yanlış olan bir şey vardır Tıpkı
lisedeki haline dönen bir şeyin peşinden
çok koşarsanız O sizin peşinizden koşmaz
Neyi kastettiğini anladınız
paranın peşinden koştuğunuz zaman para
asla sizin peşinizden koşmuyor Siz
başarının peşinden koştuğunuz da bir
bakıyorsunuz ki para kazanırsınız o
noktadan sonra da işte başarının peşinde
koşmaya başladım ben de fakat şöyle bir
özelliği var
Bu çocukluğuma Ben bir esnaf olarak
Zından Baba diye bir süngerci abinin
yanında başladım bana bir küçük bir
tabure verdi 12 yaşındayım dedi ki
kapılarında dur gelene geçene Buyrun
dedi ben ilk elli boyunu içime söyledi
mu ne yaptım çünkü sokaktan geçen
insanlara Buyrun de mi Bir yılın sonunda
300 metre aşağıdan
sünger almayacak adamı ikna edip Sünger
almaya getiriyorum Dükkanı
yani dişimi geçirdiğim zaman Cup alana
kadar bırakma bu alışkanlığı edindim
programı satmaya gittim
bir televizyon kanalının patronuna Tabi
o zaman çok başarılı işler yapıyoruz
şirkette sağolsunlar seviyorlarsa
yollarda bize gittim Dedim ki bu böyle
bir iş yaptım ben dedim
salon kahkahalardan yıkıldı montaja
girdik montajı ben buna montaj yapmak
istemiyorum çok komik dedi Yani ben
seyirciye Tolga'ya kendime her şey çok
güveniyorum gittim koydum ortaya Bizim
memlekette genelde bir şey çok fazla
inanıp çok fazla güvendiğinizde ve bunu
karıştırma hissettirdiğinizde ben şunu
güvenini bir yerle bir dediğim diye bir
tavır olabiliyor Bu da ben yıllar sonra
anladım Yani açıkla yakalamanız Evet
arkadaşlar aşırı özgüvenli aşırı
inanarak
Bulunduğunuz yerde O televizyon patron
şöyle birşey yaptığı saat sevdiğim
saydığım Ya abi dir Ama bu benim asla
hayatımın sonuna kadar unutamayacağım
bir şeydi Rize programı
telefona yardımcılarına aradı Ben dedim
ki tamam dedim adlı programı
yardımcıları Hayır geldiler onlar da
çağırdı seyirci kaldı dedi ki tur at bir
şey getirdi
ama dedi şöyle bir şey yapacak dedi açtı
programı yandan program çalıyor Tolga
bağırıyor Tolga da karşılık veriyor Dedi
Evet Dedi 90 dakika yapacak dedi Evet
dedim
Haftada bir gün yapacak dedi Evet dedim
ve bunu televizyonda yayınlanacak dedi
Evet dedim
Sonra benimle alay ettiler 30 dakika
falan
Bütün arkadaşlar ve şöyle bir şey
söyledim ama sen çok akıllı bir çocuksun
çok da güzel işler yapıyorsun Hadi
bakalım canım o işlerden getir bize dedi
beni gönderdi tabi şirkete ben Okan kötü
hissettim kendimi sonra şirketi tekrar
geldim montaj diyorsun kapısına geldim
herkes hala çok gülüyordu projeye
Dedim ki hani
bunu yapmam lazım dedim kendi kendime
işte
dedim ya arkasından 4-5 tane reklam
kampanyası salonda oynuyoruz hala 16
yılı projenin ağzına kadar doluyor Çok
şükür işte bu ayın sonunda tekrar
Türkiye turnesine çıkıyoruz Avrupa
turnesine çıkıyoruz dünya turnesine
çıkıyor Ben bambaşka bir şey oldu
30 dakika alay edilen bir projenin bu
hale gelmesinin
temelinde yatan şey ısırdığı zaman kopar
ana kadar bırakmayın arkadaşlar ve bir
şey yapmak için çok büyük bir hikayesi
olmasına gerek yok yok Sizin inandığınız
size İyi hissettiren hikayenin olması
daha önemli bir isim ama filmi yazmak
için bu işte yıllardır oturup bir şeyler
yazıp bir kenara atıyorum Bugün
bir reklam filmi geldi
otizmli çocuklarla ilgili Ben de
ailelerine karşılaşma fırsatı buldu
röportaj yapılıyor soruluyor ne yapmak
istersiniz hayattaki en büyük mutluluk
Çocuğunuz Ne Yaparsan çok mutlu
olursunuz diye
bir hanımefendi dedi ki benim oğlum dedi
ayakkabısını Bağlar sadece hayattaki en
mutlu insan olurum dedi
Allah Allah ağabey bir beton vurmuş gibi
oldu Sonra bir baba geldi gene aynı
soruyu sorduk dedik ki benim Çocuğunuz
ne yaparsa çok mutlu olursunuz dedik
dediki
gömleğini dedi kendisi ilikler sen dedi
Ben bu hayattaki en mutlu insan olurum
dedi
Sonra bir baba daha geldi dedi ki bir
kere dedi kafasını kaldırsın gözümün
içine baksın ben sonra Evet
şimdi dedim ya
bu tekrar eve geldim Bir de film yapmak
istediğimiz bir ortam vardı
Benim şirketteki Ortamda çok inandı
ilerledi fakat gene muffin meselelerini
konuşurken birisi bana dedi ki hikayenin
çok küçük dedi
yani Hikayem şu otizmli bir çocuk bir
gün babasının gözünün içine bakar 90
dakika bu babanın acısını anlatıp
90'ıncı dakikada çocuğun Kafasını
kaldırıp babasının gözünün içine bakması
dedim hikaye bana dediler ki hikayenin
çok küçük Ben de dedim ki hikayenin
küçüklüğü değil hani derinliği Çünkü
bana hissettirdiği şey önemli Ben o gün
o adamın söylediği şey de çok kalbim
büyüdü ben o filmi yaptım arkadaşlar
tabii filmin anlar oldu başta Kıvanç
Tatlıtuğ sağolsun gittim filmi anlattım
bu
hemen kabul etti filmi filmi yaptık 77
ülkede gösterildi
hayatımın en küçük ve en önemli
hikayelerinden
bir tanesi oldu film yani
küçük Hikayemiz var diye asla Benim
Hikayem çok küçük ben bu hikayeden nasıl
büyük bir hayat yaratırım peşinde
koşmanın da gerek yok ya şunu
hissetmeniz Yeter mi Sen Azim meselesi
vardır ya
bugün kalaycı'nın Birine bir çocuk
getiriyor annesi yok ki bunun babası yok
diyor senin yanında çalışabilir mi diyor
kadrajda Tabii ki çalışabilir Neden
olmasın diyor çocuğa diyor işte tepsi
böyle çeviriyorsun kolay diyorsun
çeviriyorsun Kalay diyorsun diyor Ertesi
gün çocuk İşe gelmiyor Kalaycı da merak
ediyor aynı babası yok çocuğun başına
bir şey gelmiş olmasında evine gidiyor
kapıyı çalıyor annesi açıyor kapıyı
diyor ki Ama efendi oğlumuz gelmedi
bugün işe diyor abi diyorum O nereden
biliyorsunuz diyor Neden gelmedi ediyor
öğrenmiş oluyor Neyi öğrenmiş böyle
tepsi çeviriyor musun kalıyor musun
çeviriyor musun kalıyor musun bu adam
diyor ki Eşekoğlueşek kendi öğrendiği
yetmemiş anasına da öğretmiş diyor
önemli olan kalaylanan nasıl yapıldığı
değil orada bulunmak bak orada bulunmaya
azmetmek Ve sonunda da bir başarıya
ulaşmak başarıya ulaşmanın
ya başarılı olduktan sonra ki size
hissettirdiği şeyin ne olduğu konusunda
da En ufacık bir fikrim yok
yani nasıl bir haz duyduğum konusunda
şöyle bir iğrenç tarafı var onu söyleyim
başarılı olduğunuzda devamlı başarılı
olmak
bak hissi doğuyor ve siz günün sonunda
başarıya sevilemez hale geliyorsunuz
Sabah işte bizim işte bilirsiniz
reytingler çıkar bir açarsan program 1.
olmuş Allah Yandık bir kere 2 gittiniz a
hayatınız kayar
ben mutlu olmak için kendine sebep
yaratma kendi küçük hikayelerini
yaratmak ve iki aylarla mutlu olmak
Bence daha önemli
çünkü ölçülebilen tek şey Sizsiniz işte
bir metre uzunluğu bize söylemişler Şu
kadar bir şey dediler bir kilo bu kadar
bir şey dediler işte bilmem kaç bit Şu
kadar bir şey diye hepsi birilerinin
bize öğrettiği bir şey ya bu ölçü Budur
diye benim hayatta hiç kimseye inanmadan
kendi kendine ispatladım tek gerçek ölçü
birimi Ben biliyorum Aşık Oldum
terkedildim acılarını yaşadım
sevinçlerini yaşadım test ettim
onayladım Ben gerçek bir birim ve bunu
mutlu etmek için
ya bu mutluluğu yaşamak için Oscar
almanıza gerek yok arkadaşlar Oscar
aldığınızda Annenize yaptığımız
konuşmada annenizin babanızın duyduğu
gururla
bayramda size bu sütlü kadayıf yaparak
Deniz sonra bugün alzaymır olur siz ona
sütlü kadayıf yapıp bayramda elini
öpmeye gidersiniz o zaman sizinle
duyduğu gurur arasında hiçbir fark yok
mesele annenizin babanızın gururunu
almak satar vicdanlı birisiniz vicdanlı
değilseniz paranın peşinde koşarsınız
parayı başarı sanırsınız Aslında para
akıl değildir para akıl değildir para
akıl değildir parayı Allah istediğini
verir bazen yolda bulursunuz bazen Milli
Piyango'dan çıkar
bazen de istemeden bir şey yaparsınız o
sırada o denk gelmiştir Hani derler ya
Allah Yürü ya kulum dedi diye öyle gider
O ama parası olan insanda akıllı insan
değildir para da akıl değildir önemli
olan sizin kendi mutluluğumuzu bulmanız
Dur şimdi bu kadar aldıkları yapıyorum
çünkü tekstile İnsan kendi hayatından
bir şeyler anlatması lazım ya siz
et ki bütün bunları anlattıktan o tırnak
içinde kendimi de işte beş çocuklu bir
memur ailenin çocuğu olarak geldiği
noktada başarılı bulursam söyleyeceğim
şey şu Evet
bir sürü iş yaptım çok başarılı oldu
hala devam ediyor çok şükür
abi Şeker hastasıyım Yüksek tansiyon var
obsesif kompulsif bozukluğun var
anksiyete bozukluğu var ayakkabı bağı
ile ilikleme den dolaşa biliyorum uçağa
bilemiyorum vapura bilemiyorum trene
bilemiyorum başkasının kullandığı
arabaya bilemiyorum Çok ciddi endişe
yaşıyorum her sabah uyandığımda Acaba
bugün ne oldu diye bir ip endişeyle
uyanıyorum
yani şu ana kadar anlattım her şeyi bu
son anlattığım cümleden silip şuna
dönebilirsiniz kendi küçük mutluluk
larımızı kendi vicdanınızla ve kendi
iyiliğiniz de bulabilirsiniz tek
tavsiyem şu kötü bir insan olmayıp iyi
insan olmak için çabalayıp ve
Vicdanınızın sesine kulak verin Çok
teşekkür ederim
abone ol